mặc em này Ra biển auto lên vibe
bỏ Ra hơn một 20 mà đổi lại một
outfit nhìn mờ mờ ảo ảo là lướt đúng chất mùa hè
áo sơ mi đan lưới đích thị là con thun Summer vibe 2.026
kiểu áo nhìn qua tưởng đơn giản
AI ngờ lên người lại ăn xiềng cực
gió lùa qua lớp vải lưới mát rượi
đứng giữa trời nắng vẫn thấy thoải mái
form rộng nên mặc lên kiểu gì cũng hợp
đi lại thoải mái không bị bí bách
cái khiến em này viral là vibe nửa kín nửa hở đúng trend
không cần hở quá đà mà vẫn đủ để outfit có điểm nhấn
lên hình là thấy ánh nắng xuyên qua
lốc phải tạo hiệu ứng mờ mờ ảo ảo
nhìn phát là biết đang ở biển
phối đồ thì đơn giản level Max
bên trong quàng đại tank top hoặc áo thun mỏng
dưới là quần short là xong
không cần suy nghĩ nhiều
vẫn có ngay set đồ đi biển chuẩn TikTok
giá chỉ hơn một 20 mà lên
outfit nhìn đắt vibe hẳn nên mới có chuyện
AI đi biển cũng phải có ít nhất một em
không phải trend thoáng qua
mà là kiểu năm nào hè tới cũng quay lại
và năm nay thì còn hot hơn nữa